I'm a hot over the first table please
three minutes three moves great Oman
Adriana are attempting to elevate the
cheapest cuts of pork up to my mission
in standards can they really make a silk
purse out of a sow's ear when we come
together so you've got a bit of teamwork
going on there yeah I don't want that
food hanging around here too long when
it's cooked like that I want it out yes
to make sure all five elements reach the
table piping hot and beautiful succulent
they must pull together our second time
to come to help them so you did it for
place that's also it works a team
involved you okay just about perfection
that's all come on you got it what
weasel play so I've got the ambassador
of Spain out there guys yeah I want
everything done and that's the tongue
layer yes
he's managed to impress my diners with
his challenging ingredients once but can
Omar pull it off again please everyone
please
never tried to dump before by surprise
really real nice service is over okay
good well done what I was before I taste
both dishes I'm keen to find out what my
guests thought of them starting with el
pirata
let's talk pork the Wellington the
Potters and extraordinary both are very
good but LP rod has been more creative
in texture in flavor I love piñatas but
I thought this could've been with a bit
more pink chocolate and a bit less
pastry but you know delicious you know
pinky Astros will help it oughta be so
generous about fee nose dish
talk to about the pork chop yeah it was
great I really enjoyed the combination
and flavors was great nothing it was
just that understanding English it was
really really good
their final dish was a very simple dish
on a very very well beautiful I prefer
the female Asian I think it's more
simple but at the end it was better for
me the other one it was too much
tonight I've witnessed some of the most
outstanding food in the competition from
two remarkable chefs
with try our best we put a lot of
passion and knowledge into our
preparation service went too smooth so
I'm very happy very pleased I'm happy
with my dish we love to win yeah
now I have the impossible task of
choosing which of these two will go
through to my semi-finals
you